I'm Austan wintry and I'm a composer who
does games and films and all kinds of
other things being a composer in the
21st century is the best time period for
that line of work you know of all
history because you have every single
genre and medium that composers have
worked in historically writing
symphonies string quartets operas all
the rest of it and 10,000 new ones
whether it's video games which itself is
an umbrella term can mean anything from
from you know clash Royale mobile titles
up to gigantic budget triple a console
titles or whatnot and everything in
between there's of course film there's
television and television itself is this
exploding concept that doesn't really
mean one thing anymore either and just
because of the internet you can also
just kind of dream up whatever you want
and and I could just make videos of
myself playing piano and figure out cool
ways to shoot it and create an audience
on YouTube through you know Instagram
and Twitter and the rest of it things
like that and so it's it's like the
world has become this very flexible
piece of dough that we can shape to be
essentially whatever you want as artists
and I don't think there's any time
period that can hold a moat torch to
that prior to today because of the fact
that the tools have become so
democratized which I think enhances
creativity it also greatly widens the
playing field and so in order to get
paid for it you have to stand out all
the more you have to be more uniquely
you
so for composers just getting into the
business the advice I always have to
offer is not about gear or about
meetings or what kind of you know
conventions to go to or any of that kind
of stuff it's figuring out what makes
you you in this very authentic way and
embrace that to the point that you're
actually divisive amongst audience
members it goes against our survival
instinct as aspiring composers to
potentially turn people off by making
such stark creative choices that we know
it will be kind of offensive to some but
it won't be offensive to everybody and
those it's not it'll be like a magnet
and even if it's one person I think
that's a better way to to do your career
than to join the kind of endless sea of
generic faceless personality list music
that exists out
there because a lot of that I think is
written from a place of fear and so try
to get over your fear and just be you
which I know is easier said than done
but all the composers I admire most
that's the one thing they all seem to
have in common the criteria for a new
project is its threefold but it's really
primarily between the first two which is
who am i working with so it doesn't
matter to me what the game is in terms
of genre medium console release that
kind of thing know that matters to me
compared to who it is there are certain
people that I would just I would go over
a cliff for them because we've been in
the trenches together you know I mean
that game company is a great example
where we did flow and then of course
this incredible experience together on
journey he was life-changing both during
and afterward and so it's for them they
say jump I say how high that kind of
thing that matters to me far more than
any other and so most the times and I
work with someone it's immediately about
the chemistry of the collaborators
because you bleed together that that's
the thing it's so deeply collaborative
there's so much about the openness of
their ideas and their openness to my
idea is that that matters the most and
then the second criteria would be the
musical opportunity is it give me a
chance to do something I never done
before now if it's somebody I've worked
with and I love them that becomes less
important to me but if it's a new
relationship then that's the first thing
I look to what can I do that feels fresh
then only once you've got all that
figured out do I start thinking about
the basics of how does it pay what's the
schedule that kind of thing but the
first two matters so much more to me one
of the most exciting things about
writing music for games is the feeling
of being on the frontier of an entirely
new form of artistic expression because
the thing is interactive media gives you
this variable to contend with that film
and radio and theater and opera and all
the rest of that they're all linear they
don't have this the non-linearity of
games to me is as novel as imagining
being a composer a hundred years ago and
saying hey turns out we don't just have
to be in the room we can record this and
what if we don't just think of recording
sessions as documentaries of the event
of the performance but we start trying
to create something that would be almost
hyper real where the microphone gets in
closer than any audience member ever
could are we
in ways and suddenly recording becomes
its own artform that completely and
totally changes music for all time the
last time there was that big of a
paradigm shift was recording as today
games to me shake things up as much or
more than that did so I think we have no
idea where this is going and we are all
blindly fumbling in the dark and it's
awesome my ultimate hero is Jerry
Goldsmith and what I loved about Jerry
was he was insanely prolific he was like
Bach you know Bach had to write one mass
each week you know I mean it's just the
sheer amount and but he was working
composer that was the idea you know this
was the gig Jerry felt the same way
about movies you know movie shows up and
he just says hey when you need it done
I'm gonna have it done my agent used to
represent him and called him a
blue-collar genius because Jerry's
mentality was just I like to work and
this is a job and it's like being a
carpenter or any other but the thing was
it's like being the world's greatest
carpenter if you're Jerry Goldsmith
because as much as he thought of it as
being very workman like or purely about
craft he was in this incredible artist
so as a result he was deeply chameleon
ik his music ran every genre you could
possibly imagine and yet when you study
his work you realize below that surface
of genre conventions and choices of
instruments and that kind of thing
there's a very consistent voice as an
artist that's very strong I mean you can
spot Jerry's music once you know it
within five seconds that's unmistakably
Goldsmith and that to me became the
model I loved the idea that genre is
actually superficial and I liken it to
the clothes that I wear like today I'm
wearing this tie and a black shirt and I
look you know border I'm threatening to
look posh
if I dare borrow British language but
other days it's just a t-shirt that's 15
years past when it should have been
thrown out and tennis shoes that have
holes in them and that kind of thing and
the way I see it is that's genre the
clothes I'm wearing are not the same
thing is the person wearing the clothes
and so to me the idea of being diverse
or
sort of chameleon in one's work is is
ultimately addressing the surface of
what they're doing it's not who they are
on a deeper level there are very few of
my kind of film heroes still around but
Peter McConnell for example is one of my
absolute all-time favorite composers he
did all of the LucasArts titles of the
90s and the
which is for me my other favorite game
scorer of all time grim fandago and he
continues to be incredibly relevant in
the industry you know very one of the
very few composers who got their start
in the 80s and early 90s are still part
of the actual forefront of the
conversation today I mean that's just
such an enduring career it's hard in any
medium to to last that long but you know
he's the composer of hearthstone and and
all the current you know Psychonauts 2
which is forthcoming and everyone's
always excited what Double Fine's up to
and etcetera etcetera etc and so the
fact that I get to call him not just a
hero but a good close personal friend is
mind-boggling to me because I grew up
listening to his music and so for me
that that's a selling point of the game
industry you know your heroes work
alongside you almost undoubtedly the
industry is still so young is populated
by a lot of new voices and there's
people that I consider heroes of mine
who are lateral heroes we I don't I
didn't look up to them as a kid I look
up to them from across the aisle as it
were and and of course I make no or I I
don't hide at all that a Jessica curry
is probably the the chief amongst those
she's someone who's writing I I have
endless love for and then she's a human
being we've spent some time together
multiple occasions being able to look up
to someone and then call them a
colleague and then being able to just
look across and say wow you're brilliant
you you actually make me be better
because you're setting the bar like this
I mean how could I
how could I have any self-respect and
work alongside you and not give it my
all because otherwise you're just get
them leave me in the dust here the
legends of film are from like the 30s
and 40s I mean some of there are people
that have been dead for half a century
games just not that way I've seen all
artists fall prey to this idea there's
this logical loop that forms where I you
know hypothetically I write a piece of
music and I struggle and I pull my hair
out and I die for it and then I put it
out there and people seem to like it and
they say oh this is a good piece of
music and then I make this logical
equivocation good piece of music must be
written by good composers well if I
wrote this piece and the world has
deemed it good then by default I must be
a good composer problem is when I then
go to write the next piece of music it's
like this hand is writing a piece of
music well if this is a good composer
writing this then this must be a good
piece of music
and I didn't go through all that
struggle that made the first one
potentially any good and so by believing
this notion that I am amazing I actually
create a very short shortcut to
mediocrity I'm not a fan of this kind of
false humility detachment I I'm very
grateful that people have been so
generous towards me and like the BAFTAs
as a perfect example I've gotten noticed
there multiple times in every single
time it was genuinely a privilege and
it's an honor and I'm always really
grateful that that project is getting
some notice because I by the time I
finish something I'm usually really
passionate that that game get as much
notices but never mind the score I just
want the game to get in if the score can
help further that then that's great
games are an unstoppable juggernaut I
think by the end of the 21st century
they will have clearly dominated as the
primary kind of vehicle for cultural
engagement and storytelling and that
kind of thing in the way that film is
unquestionably the dominant voice of
storytelling of the 20th century so I
don't think it's a matter of of course
everybody that advocates for it
everybody that is out there evangelizing
much like yourselves at BAFTA and even
just self starting communities out there
fans basically as much as all of that is
so powerful and meaningful I think games
are selling themselves I think that
especially now that you can play games
on a mobile device that everybody owns
and you can make really legitimate
artistic titles I mean we were talking
about Florence Florence a perfect
example that is a game that there is
ZERO barrier to entry you don't need a
Nintendo or a Playstation and iPhones
Androids those don't have the stigma for
that increasingly small group of the
population that thinks it's somehow
weird to go buy a video game machine but
the beautiful thing is that sentence is
increasingly out of date also I mean the
idea of people who find it bizarre to go
invest in a Playstation that's just a
shrinking demographic it just simply is
and so for me games they're on their way
there's no there's no stopping them is
even if there are naysayers out there
they're not driving the conversation I
mean people are creating increasingly
personal increasingly evocative
increasingly diverse types of content
that applies to or appeals to all types
of hue
beings and it's only getting it more and
more and more I'm gonna be like judging
literature based on what was a
contemporary of Beowulf I mean what what
what on earth that were putting the cart
before the horse a little bit I think
and so our judging film by what the
biggest hits of 1931 were you know I
mean it's just the the best is yet to
come for sure my goal is certainly to
look back on something like journey in
10 or 15 years and laugh and be like I
can't believe we thought that was
interesting look what's happening today
and I think it's gonna happen regardless
of if I want it to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]